hey guys dr. Berg here listen out of all
the videos that I've done this is
probably the most important video and
you'll see why because there is so much
confusion so much false information that
it's very complex for people so I want
to break it down step by step it's a
little bit longer but it's very
important so we're going to answer the
question is the so-called bad
cholesterol LDL really that bad
okay well first of all LDL is not
cholesterol in order for to transport
cholesterol through the body which is
fat doesn't mix with water it just
doesn't mix so the bias has developed a
little shuttles or different particles
or vehicles to transport cholesterol
okay and you have LDL low-density
lipoprotein and you have HDL
high-density lipoprotein LDL which is
considered bad really is a kind of a
misnomer because LDL really is the
cholesterol that goes from the liver to
the vascular system to the cells so it's
going through the into the body okay HDL
is this the opposite it's going from the
vascular system back to the liver to be
recycled or eliminated okay
so really these two types of proteins
are exchangers that are just constantly
working together to exchange cholesterol
back and forth to transport cholesterol
and triglycerides which are blood fats
okay so that's the first thing you need
to understand let's go to the next part
okay so you may already know that the
body makes cholesterol right it makes a
lot 3,000 milligrams every single day
that's equivalent to about 14 eggs the
cholesterol in 14 eggs the cholesterol
in 300 strips of bacon or the
cholesterol in about a pound of butter
okay that's a lot of cholesterol now why
does it make so much well it's there to
provide raw material for cell membranes
have to sell all the cells in the body
are made out of cholesterol and you have
a hundred trillion cells
that's why we need so much cholesterol
so it's part of the structural property
of a membrane around your cell which
allows exchange back and forth of
nutrients and vitamins and minerals and
glucose and all sorts of things so it
also has antioxidant properties it
prevents free radical damage and it's
anti-inflammatory properties it makes
vitamin D it's the precursor the
building blocks for vitamin D it
actually helps you make bile that then
helps you dissolve the fat and extract
the fat type of vitamins from the fact
that you eat very important that without
cholesterol you can't have that happen
cholesterol is there to make the stress
hormone cortisol and cortisol is
essential for life and all the sex
hormones testosterone estrogen
progesterone are all made from
cholesterol these are the normal
functions of cholesterol but you have
additional functions that a lot of
people don't know about because
cholesterol also responds to crisis like
if someone has an infection the body
cholesterol will go up because it binds
and inactivates bacterial toxins it also
prevents the damage from microbes it
also acts as a band-aid so in the cell
membrane you have the endothelial layer
which is the layer around inside of the
blood vessel okay
and that actually has little pores that
exchange back and forth white blood
cells nutrition things go back and forth
so if you were to get a little tiny
lesion ulcer damage from various things
which I'll cover in a bit the
cholesterol is there to go in there and
help heal and actually to provide a
band-aid that's the real purpose ok
let's go to the next part okay so now
this part is very very important so if
you've checked out just check back in
with me hang in there because this is
the most vital piece of this puzzle okay
there's two types of LDL when you get
your LDL checked on your routine
cholesterol assessment it doesn't
differentiate between this type or that
type so it's type A
or type B or they can call it pattern a
or pattern B okay they don't
differentiate the two the type a is
large buoyant that means it floats right
it's big and fluffy it doesn't go into
the epithelial wall it doesn't create
involved event any clacking or clotting
of anything like that so this is more
normal LDL okay this type B are small
dense these keep these little guys can
go right into the epithelial wall and
they can start to be involved in the
plaquing formation so when people have
heart attacks and strokes you know they
have more of type B okay it makes sense
so you see more oxidation and build up
plaque type a it pretty much last two
days in your body type B lasts about
five days so it hangs out longer so how
do you know which is which you can do a
very advanced test if you want but a
better thing to do an easier thing to do
I wouldn't say it's better but it's
easier is to look at the triglycerides
and the HDL okay so let's say your LDL
is normal or high whatever if your
triglycerides because there is a
percentage of triglycerides in LDL in
addition to cholesterol if you look at
the triglycerides and the HDL if the
triglycerides are high and the HDL
so-called good cholesterol is low then
chances are you have more type B
LDL okay but if the triglycerides are
low and you have high HDL you have more
type a so that's how you would
differentiate what type you would have
the last point I want to mention is this
what types of foods will increase type A
versus type B saturated fats will
increase type A interesting
when you consume more carbs and refined
sugars and sugar itself you increase
type B and this is why nearly all the
blood assessments that I see we pick
patients come in they always have high
triglycerides and low HDL the people
that are consuming carbs but if you
actually eliminate this and you do more
saturated fats you don't worry about it
because you'll have you may have even
high LDL but it's a type A that doesn't
create a problem now one last point and
this is the most important point let's
say you do have type B it's not that
it's a bad cholesterol it's not the
villain it's not the criminal it's at
the crime scene but it's there to
actually heal the lesion the problem the
inflammation the damage from the
inflammation or the microbes that's
behind it and so this is only bad in
that it's part of the chain of events
that occurs that it's they're trying to
fix things but in the process it doesn't
think the body doesn't think long term
it thinks with short-term survival so
it's going to form a plaque and a clot
to try to peel the area just like you
would if you sprained an ankle or broke
a joint scar tissue comes in and heal it
it doesn't care if the joint moves
anymore
it's there to protect and stop the
motion so yes it creates the problem
because you will die have a heart attack
and stroke but the body's not thinking
long term is thinking let's go ahead and
patch that artery and let's start
putting a band-aid and starts growing
bigger and bigger and bigger the point
is that we need to change the eating
plan we need to get these out of the
diet and then your body can assimilate
these a lot better all right so now
let's go to the next part okay so now
the question is why would someone have
high LDL pattern B okay we already
talked about the sugar right because
sugar creates inflammation it's very
destructive to the cells that's why
diabetics have a lot of nerve damage
vision problems inflammation coronary
heart disease so sugar and refined carbs
are
really bad okay also low thyroid will
create it high cortisol will create
higher amounts of pattern B stress
vegetable oils the soy in the corn oil
and canola all that GMO that's
vegetables it's high in omega-6 fatty
acids that creates more inflammation in
the body
trans fats hydrogenated partially
hydrogenated fats will do it low vitamin
C just like a situation you get bleeding
gums you get bleeding arteries glycation
what does glycation that's when you
combine glucose or fructose with a
protein or a fat so let's say you take
barbecued sauce and you put it on some
ribs and you bake it you heat it over
all 200 I think in 48 degrees Fahrenheit
you're going to get glycation so the
glycation means that it's this
combination of sugar with protein that
goes in the body it's very sticky and it
starts creating high level of the
pattern B among other issues as well
fries so they take sugar and they spray
it on french fries they deep-fry it same
deal doughnuts deep-fried Donuts
glycation what's interesting is so you
when you combine protein with sugar or
sugar with fat and you bake it or you
cook it you create glycation also when
you consume high fructose corn syrup or
fructose in the form of refined fructose
or a tremendous amount of fructose you
can increase glycation by 10 times okay
because it combines in your body so not
only does it have to be you know
external it could be internally as well
okay and then surgery will increase
pattern B because of because LDL is a
healer it's trying to go in there like
an ambulance and actually fix thing
that's the purpose it's trying to help
you and what do people do they take a
statin they try to limit it it's not
understanding why we need LDL visceral
fat will also trigger
pattern B as well so anyway those are
the things that will increase the real
it's not bad cholesterol it's the it's
the cholesterol that creates that's
involved in the crime singing the damage
alright okay in summary we just want to
understand cholesterol LDL what it is
and what it's not and uses an indicator
to pull the string to find out why it
might be high if it's higher it could be
normal if the triglycerides are normal
and the HDL is normal but if there is
the problem with these then you have to
under ask why do I have a hypothyroid
issues am i eating too much sugar am i
doing this and the did I just get them
with some surgery of trauma alright
thanks for watching put your comments
below hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you a report